[Musica]
sono sempre presa ragazza che la mattina
si alza si prepara e prende il treno
delle 7:50 da Gambettola diretto verso
Cesena per andare a scuola
ho frequentato come di norma le
elementari le medie e ora mi ritrovo al
quinto superiore del liceo linguistico
Ilaria Alpi
non ho molti hobby Ma quelli che holi
coltiva appieno come il pianoforte e la
fotografia
Insomma sono una semplice normale
diciottenne che il sabato sera esce con
gli amici a divertirsi che spesso si
ritrova a discutere con i genitori per
cose banali e che per scappare dai
problemi si rifugia nella musica
Eppure la domanda che mi viene posta più
spesso e a cui faccio più fatica a
rispondere
Ma tu di dove sei
[Applauso]
come ci si sente a rimanere spiazzati
davanti a una domanda che apparentemente
potrebbe sembrare così semplice da
rispondere Ecco questo è ciò che mi
ritrovo ad affrontare ogni volta che mi
viene posta una domanda simile
di solito risponde in modo molto vago
come sono nata qui in Italia ma ho
origini cinesi è un trucco che mi
avevano insegnato alle elementari e che
ammetto tuttora funziona ma
effettivamente non è una risposta molto
precisa
Quest'anno ho compito 18 anni e se da
una parte è una tappa bellissima
dall'altro mi ha dato da pensare Ok come
a tutti forse o forse no
Ma cosa c'entrano i 18 anni con la
domanda inquisitoria Ecco apparentemente
a prima vista sembrerebbe non esserci
alcuna correlazione ma oggi vorrei farvi
vedere queste due cose sotto un'altra
diversa luce
sotto la mia luce
ho tratti somatici chiaramente asiatici
nello specifico cinesi come d'altronde i
miei genitori i mezzi i miei nonni e
tanti altri parenti
C'è una differenza però
perché io al raggiungimento della
maggiore età ho dovuto fare una scelta
se rimanere con la nazionalità cinese o
ottenere la cittadinanza italiana
e no mi sono fatta la vostra stessa
domanda non è possibile mantenere
entrambe le città di danze Dunque
ottenere la doppia cittadinanza e questo
è stato il motivo del mio tormento in
questo intero continuando
da una parte la cultura gli amici con
cui sono a contatto quotidianamente è
sicuramente quella italiana
dall'altra i miei tratti fisici e le mie
tipiche tradizioni cinesi fanno parte
del mio essere del mio vivere in
famiglia
mettiamo come se volessi ottenere la
cittadinanza italiana
Pensateci ho letteralmente vissuto
l'ambiente la vita in questo paese in
cui sono nata e in cui ho vissuto le mie
prime esperienze
Nonostante io mi fossi integrata davvero
bene
nonostante l'epoca in cui viviamo
nonostante la modernizzazione su certe
tematiche attuali quindi in Italia
affrontate discusse e sensibilizzate
continuano a rimanere saldi numerosi
stereotipi per un semplice tratto fisico
e somatico soprattutto
E questa cosa si riflette anche su di me
visto la gente anche chi non mi conosce
mi
etichetta come quella cinese
o quella con gli occhi a mandorla e
questo mi fa dubitare se effettivamente
io possa considerare l'Italia un paese
anche mio
Certamente se mi trasferissi in Cina
questo problema si risolverebbe sicuro
ma Pensateci sarebbe un ambiente
totalmente diverso e inoltre appena si
viene a sapere che ho letteralmente
vissuto tutta la mia vita in un paese
all'estero anche lì verrà etichettata
come quella italiana
Insomma è una continua crisi di
nazionalità possiamo chiamarla in cui ti
porta a non sapere più chi sei veramente
E soprattutto chi vuoi essere in futuro
come ci si sente ad essere diversi In
entrambe le situazioni
scomodo ve lo dico io molto scomodo
Questa è la mia condizione
ma è anche la condizione di milioni di
altri ragazzi e ragazze che vengono
comunemente chiamate considerati
stranieri appunto ragazzi e ragazze che
vengono giudicati e stereotipati per un
semplice tratto somatico o un nome e
cognome fuori dalla quotidiana normalità
Appunto
dunque non è un dilemma solo per me
Mi spiego meglio
l'Italia è un paese che per legge
dà la possibilità e al diritto di
ottenere la cittadinanza per gli
stranieri in maniera appunto doppia
quindi essere cittadini di più stati
gli stranieri possono Dunque ottenere la
cittadinanza italiana senza dover
necessariamente rinunciare a quella già
tenuta
sempre se il paese di origine lo
consenta
Infatti ci sono numerosi paesi che non
permettono la doppia cittadinanza con
l'Italia oltre alla Cina vi sono per
esempio la Spagna L'Irlanda la Norvegia
o il Giappone e tanti altri con cui sono
anche dei paesi moderni possiamo dire e
qui possiamo vedere che la lista scorre
lunga Appunto
come e a chi chiedere aiuto per compiere
questa scelta
di solito i genitori sono un punto di
riferimento per i propri figli
soprattutto quando hanno problemi ma in
questo caso parlando anche di esperienza
personale
i miei non si sono mai posti il problema
e non si sono mai chiesti se come si
potesse sentire la propria figlia in un
paese all'estero in un paese fuori dalla
appunto dall'estero
e dunque non ho potuto contare sul loro
appoggio e ho dovuto
elaborare una mia personale risposta e
un mio personale pensiero
Ecco perché oggi sono qui a proporvi la
mia idea
è semplice forse scontata ma non ancora
applicata possiamo dire
aprire la propria mente
non solamente gli occhi
Bisognerebbe Infatti relazionarsi con
una persona considerata diversa
senza essere effettivamente condizionati
da chi è veramente
pensate per esempio a quante occasioni
si perdono esordendo semplicemente con
una domanda sbagliata
si potrebbe conoscere qualcuno con una
personalità davvero interessante e non
diversa bensì arricchita di una cultura
in più
ricorda anche un semplice sguardo strano
a una persona diversa anche senza
rendersene conto
potrebbe mandare in crisi la persona a
fianco a te
Tu non sai chi è tu non la conosci
Potrebbe parlare la tua stessa lingua e
perfettamente inoltre
Eppure tu l'hai già etichettata per un
semplice tratto somatico
fastidioso ve la sicuro
Bisognerebbe Dunque cambiare la propria
visione delle cose in questo momento
della società è Infatti fondamentale
i figli di immigrati cresciuti in questo
paese hanno vissuto le tue stesse
esperienze e dunque non è più necessario
dargli un etichetta in stereotipo per un
semplice tratto somatico Come si è
sempre fatto
e dunque
Come ci si allena per aprire la mente
Se ci pensate per fare bene uno sport ci
sono regole ci sono tecniche e ci sono
abilità da sviluppare
Ecco quindi
come ci si allena per abbattere i
pregiudizi e gli stereotipi
beh
è sicuramente un fattore che deve essere
contrastato dalla sua radice e un'ottima
soluzione è appunto per mezzo
dell'educazione scolastica
oggigiorno la discriminazione è un tema
molto ricorrente e delicato di cui si
dovrebbe continuare a parlare e
affrontare
Infatti sensibilizzare su una tematica
del genere sin dalla giovane età
potrebbe portare a un cambiamento
drastico verso la condizione e la
visione di un individuo
arriviamo alla fine ma quindi
quale cittadinanza ho scelto
la scelta che ho fatto è stata una sfida
nei miei ultimi mesi
è stata una lotta interiore tra una
scelta più razionale Quindi ottenere la
cittadinanza italiana e una più di
tradizione mantenere la nazionalità
cinese come Effettivamente hanno fatto
anche i miei genitori
il 21 novembre 2022 il giorno del mio
compleanno
sono ufficialmente ma soprattutto
formalmente
diventata cittadina cinese
ma nonostante ciò
l'Italia resterà e resta soprattutto
anche una parte di me Sono infatti
arrivata alla conclusione che se mai
dovessi cambiare idea se mai volessi
continuare a vivere in questo paese
lavorerò con impegno per ottenere la
cittadinanza italiana e sperando che in
un futuro prossimo questo paese mi
sappia rappresentare E che soprattutto
abbia trovato un modo per affrontare le
problematiche di integrazione che ci
sono in questo momento e che abbia
trovato delle soluzioni per chiunque si
troverà come mi ci sono trovata io a
fare questa scelta Grazie
[Applauso]